mobile video app c-span now
[Music]
next deterring russian aggression in
ukraine panelists talked about military
and logistical support economic
sanctions and the goals of russian
president vladimir putin the atlantic
council hosted this hour-long
conversation
hello everyone and welcome to today's
panel how to deter russia now my name is
emily channel justice i'm the director
of the temurtay contemporary ukraine
program at harvard university's
ukrainian research institute and i'm
really delighted to be a co-sponsor of
today's event with the atlantic council
as we know we we really can't do any
more speculation about what putin's next
move will be so the essential
conversation now really has to be how do
we stop russia from invading ukraine
again
today's event will be focused on this
with a really rich panel we'll start
today's event with a keynote lecture
from philosopher filmmaker and author
bernier levy
then we'll move to a moderated
discussion which includes retired
general philip readlob the former
supreme allied commander of europe
heather conley senior vice president
europe eurasia and the arctic for the
center for strategic and international
studies
ambassador john herbst the senior
director of the eurasia center atlantic
council ambassador alexander verschbau's
distinguished fellow the atlantic
council and andrei zago rodney chair for
the center for defense strategies and
this discussion will be moderated by
melinda herring
let me turn the floor over to bernard
now thank you
hello
thanks everyone how to deter routine i
will leave the reply to the
distinguished speaker who will speak
after me
what i would what what i am what i'm
able to say first of all
is that i was there on the ground and on
the battlefield a few months ago
i went my way all through from mario
paul to luwansk and donetsk the 450
kilometers
what i witnessed a few months ago is a
situation of war
of uh
half cold and health warm war
which is nearly unthinkable
from europe and probably from america
here on this road in pitsky in
so many ghost cities you have a sort of
frozen
verdant
with
a whole network of trenches which is
real
war at the border of the west
this is the thing which to which we are
blind too often in the west but which is
a sad
and a terrible reality i'll film that
i did film it i have a lot of
footage from that
it has been
put implemented in my last movie
all these images are available
number two in the last hours days and
even hours
i received countless messages
from the spot
from comrades of the tenth assault
battalion of mountain for example
in the spot
there there is a feeling
of
a vigil of arms
which is
again
nearly unthinkable but which is the
reality which we have to think
my friends who are on the ground
feel the war
and they feel it not as a possibility
which can occur in a more or less remote
future
they feel it as a reality which could be
which is which could happen to be true
in the very very very next future
i spoke with one
friend
a few hours ago
who
told me about a rumor which is spreading
in the trenches in donbass
saying that something could happen
very close
um
for the
in a way in a tragic way celebrating the
anniversary of the collapse of soviet
union
vladimir putin being fond of these sort
of
dark and tragic anniversaries
so we are this situation we are where we
are facing
we have the moral duty to deter russia
in emergency why do we have this duty
because the ukrainians
are our allies because they have been
since
2014 our rampart against the
aggressivity and the imperialism of a
new russia or old russia as you prefer
there is a
an old eurasian
dream of putin
which is
an alternative dream from the europe
european one
and ukraine is in the middle of that it
is the first target so a country which
is our ally
which is our rampart who already spread
and spilled so much blood
for the values of europe and the values
of the west we have the moral duty to be
at
his side
i would like to add that we have
maybe more important than the moral duty
the political duty to do so political
duty because
if in the next weeks or days
or hours
the russian harmony
happened to invade
donbass
under the pretext
that donbass have been in the remote
past part of russia
under the pretext that every place in
the area where you have russian speakers
belong to russia
it is the real pandora box
which will be opened for all europe
thereafter
there will be claims in spain by the
catalans
in romania by the transylvanians
what about belgium what about
switzerland
not to speak
about i don't know even parts of america
where you speak of united states where
you speak spanish and so on if the west
accepts puts
the tip of the finger
in this narrative of putin
in this so-called common sense which
says that where you speak russian
russia is
it is a terrible precedent for all the
organized
world
so we have not only the moral duty we
have political duty to do so
and i will
want to say
uh
last word
that uh um if you see the situation from
ukraine
and again i i am receiving in the last
hour so many calls
from
good friends from there
there is a
real anxiety about the american reply
ukrainian ukraine received a lot of good
words
from america and from europe
um
the the new minister of foreign affairs
of germany
president biden president macron
expressed some strong
words
but
what are the acts for the moment
what are the concrete propositions of
deterrence
what is the calendar except
let's meet with with mr putin
in january
america and the west in general
lost so much of their credibility
in recent
years and month on other frontlines in
afghanistan in kurdistan elsewhere
what will happen in ukraine
will there is their credibility intact
in this diplomatic game do they have the
means
to be
heard and believed and taken seriously
i pray for that
because if putin happened to invade
lewansk donetsk pizki shirokiday all
these cities in ukraine
it will be a very very dirty war
this is what i foresaw when i was there
a few
months ago so i crossed my fingers
i pray and i beg
my administration and the american
administration to take
the real dimension of the tragedy which
is now cooking
thank you very much
merci beaucoup thank you so much bernard
for those profound remarks and for that
warning we're so delighted that you were
here with us thank you for your
leadership on ukraine and around the
world now it's my pleasure and bernard
we can't wait to host you at the
atlantic council in person in january so
we'll look forward to seeing with uh you
then and in the meantime you're
absolutely right to keep praying for
peace in ukraine
now
we have a fantastic panel today and we
don't have a much time so i'm going to
ask them to please give short succinct
answers
give me tv answers and i'm going to dive
in first with general breedlove general
breedlove some analysts think that
vladimir putin will go all the way and
invade ukraine others disagree almost
everyone thinks though that putin hasn't
made his mind up yet can you help us sir
how will he decide can you guide us
through putin's decision making now
well first of all anybody that tells you
know what
they know what putin is thinking i would
take them with a grain of salt so let me
just make some observations based on
what we see
uh we have to remember first this this
crisis is completely contrived it is
manufactured by putin
for a purpose and now what's important
is what is that purpose what is he
trying to get from us and that has sort
of manifested itself over the last
couple of days
and we need to keep our eyes on the
thought of protecting against the fall
of zielinski
and and protecting against the united
states taking actions that might be
inappropriate these are the ukraine
these are the nato etc that we stay on
our turf and work with our allies rather
than speak for our allies
i think mr putin's made a huge
investment
and that brings a need for recouping
from that investment
he's going to want to get the demands
that he has made and i believe that he
will continue to use this this moment
that he has manufactured and the power
on the ground until he gets those
i do believe he's taking a look though
at the cost
and finally i would just say
again we have to be careful not to
reward bad behavior
uh we we need to avoid playing this game
with ukrainian chips
or nato chips we need to stay in our
lane and not sell out our allies and
bring along our allies and others and
involve them in the things we do we have
to focus on concurrent progress on
minutes and normandy
and get a seat at the table in my humble
opinion and finally we need to remember
that the rest of the world is watching
for the results
of this bad behavior
thank you so much general appreciate
that andrew you are uh the former
minister of defense of ukraine and in
kiev so it's great to have your
perspective uh if putin invades what
would he likely take and what's his end
game i think a lot of us here are trying
to figure that out could you please
run through the most likely scenarios
uh thank you thank you very much melinda
thank you for invitation
uh first of all uh
i think that
deconstructing
all behaviors deconstructing all
scenarios and uh we we're doing this
pretty much
you know 24 7 here
uh i don't think he uh they actually
plan
uh
that this in the likely scenario would
be actually invasion i think they want
the uh west to think that they are the
invasion is imminent i think they want
the west to be scared i think they uh
want the west to to say okay we need to
do anything to avoid invasion and at the
end they want west to make concessions
and then with a great sort of um
you know gesture they they will agree
not to invade
and uh as uh some analysts including in
us said
uh institute of war studies for example
they said that if putin didn't want to
invade for the first place then he will
get all concessions pretty much giving
up nothing
uh and that's i think the most likely
scenario and i think that's that's the
plan a for them
because plans a b c wherever else looks
quite bad for putin to be honest because
what i mean he will have a huge
resistance in ukraine the ukrainian
armed forces are ready to uh apply all
their um capabilities obviously they
have huge gaps of capabilities we know
about that and obviously uh
the russia will be able to advance quite
significantly in the case of the talking
about the full-scale invasion but recent
polls which we kind of suspected but we
did recent like statistics polls and uh
and and so on are showing that a huge
number of ukrainians wants to uh and are
ready to defend participate in either
territorial defense or resistance and so
on a very very small fraction of
ukrainians want to live or even like are
happy to live under russian rule so
which means that you will uh even if you
get some territories it would be
very difficult to imagine how they're
going to hold them and how they're going
to run and affect your occupational
administration uh they don't have we
know that they're spending about two to
two to perform billion us dollars a year
to support uh
uh basically non-existent economies of
uh so-called lnr dnr
uh but uh it just it's it's unimaginable
if you can extrapolate that to the
territory of ukraine um occupying one or
two cities will
do not give them any um
doesn't give him any
any uh strategic uh advantages but
he starts all the sanctions and all kind
of resistance and everything so
essentially there is no point for them
to to to to have a small local kind of a
worse the only the only
way it would matter if they start a
full-scale invasion of the whole country
were at least half of it from like let's
say left left bank and yes area and that
that sort of thing but then we're
talking about a major war in europe
probably the biggest since the world war
ii and in this case we'll have a
substantial economic crisis for the
whole europe we'll have millions of
refugees we'll have a lot of lost
investments and so on so how your
russian economy will be able to
withstand that sort of pressure from the
world
uh for starting that it's very difficult
to imagine but certainly uh ukrainians
can promise russians to to return back
many body bags and many wounded soldiers
and we're talking about thousands uh
probably in a very short period of time
thousands and thousands that's not going
to be politically
uh welcome in russia because the
russians very i will find it very
difficult to explain why what they're
actually doing in ukraine
so generally speaking uh we have about
15 or 16 scenarios of what they can do
without a full invasion which will get
us to get the west really be scared
ukraine really be stressed the world
will be talking about the potential
invasion so like information
wise and stress-wise that would be all
got to the very limit
and that i think they will apply all
possible tools in order to
reach the concessions through those
means rather than uh
rather than face uh
an absolutely uncontrolled scenario uh
which would be for him the uh they
actually they attempt to invade you
think thanks andrew i i definitely want
to pull on some of those threads in a
minute especially on the uncertainty
thread but i want to bri i want to bring
heather into the conversation now
heather can you please um help us how
can the west get putin to leave without
appeasing him i think that's the big
question
thanks melinda uh you know i don't
believe we can uh and and in some ways
um
the kremlin understands that this is an
escalade to accommodate strategy and and
the west has has certainly followed that
approach
uh trying to
dialogue our way through this i do not
believe uh mr putin will be satisfied by
any of this and i i agreed with andrei
uh
and how he cast this uh the cost would
be great for the kremlin until the
kremlin actually published the text of
the security treaties for the us and and
for nato
and what uh president putin just said
yesterday there is no going back and so
i think it now is starting to cut off
even
uh russia uh you know trying to take a
step back and and tragically the bible
administration has now agreed to talks
once again
without requiring russia to pull away
from the border at least that occurred
in june
when president biden met with president
putin president biden was asked on the
margins of the geneva summit and
somewhat testy response would his policy
of seeking a stable and predictable
russia would that work and he said we'll
know in six months we now know in six
months and and what this tragic pattern
has occurred is the russians escalate
they get a summit they get big dialogues
nothing changes so they will see how
long they can accommodate
but the problem is
they now have set a bar so high so
publicly my fear is they have talked
putin is trying to restore this historic
loss as he's told us in june
at the 30th anniversary of the collapse
of the soviet union he's already
strategically lost ukraine in 2014 and
he lost it again spiritually in 2019
with the autocephaly so this is his
attempt to restore
this uh and i i this will be the
defining foreign policy issue for the
biden administration and i hope they
understand uh the stakes here are
absolutely enormous
thank you heather sandy same question
how can the west get putin to leave
without appeasing him what are your
thoughts on that
oh i agree we're we're very close to
what may be a point of no return for
putin
and i think you know i agree that the
publication of those two uh draft
treaties
uh
basically uh remove most of putin's
maneuvering room by making those public
he's kind of making it almost impossible
uh for us to
find some kind of way to de-escalate on
on a on a fair basis that would mean he
would pull back his his forces
and i think we were seeing that he's
quite serious in his paranoia about nato
uh he does see nato as sort of the
number one bogeyman
that uh you know is the instrument that
the main enemy the united states is
using to both undermine the putin regime
at home and deprive russia of its great
power status which for putin means
a sphere of influence and a free hand to
dominate its neighbors
so uh
i judge by putin's statement uh
yesterday at the ministry of defense
that he really believes that if he
doesn't act now
he will uh lose ukraine
forever uh
and of course underlying this is putin's
fear his and his recognition
that if ukraine does succeed in becoming
a stable prosperous western democracy
it will ultimately be a dagger pointed
at the heart of russia the power of its
example will sooner or later undermine
the whole putin regime so for putin the
stakes are survival
and that's why
he himself said there's no retreat
anymore
even though this is a manufactured
crisis as general breedlove pointed out
so
you know we have to continue to try even
as we are pessimistic about where this
is going uh to to strengthen deterrence
i think the by administration has sent a
lot of mixed signals you know nordstrom
2 has been
uh
hopeless in how we've handled that
even if it's even though it's our main
leverage or one of one of the main
points of leverage
and uh
if we agree to talks without any
pullback of the troops it also will be
another signal of weakness to the
russians uh that uh
they've got us where they want us
uh that would be a tragic misreading i
think that there is
greater unity now among allies
ironically putin is very successful in
bringing nato together as he did in 2014
he may do it again uh you know
it's hard to believe but 20 25 years
late after the nato russia founding act
we're still observing the commitments
that we made not to deploy nuclear
weapons or substantial combat forces
along russia's borders that's going to
be all bets are off for that putin's
going to create a much more threatening
environment for himself if he goes
through with this
and that's why
there may still be
a small chance of convincing him to pull
back uh but we have to play our cards
much more skillfully than we've been
doing not lee not take anything off the
table including the use of force uh it
was good that somebody leaked to david
ignatius the possibility of supporting
an insurgency uh
being ready to put at least some skin in
the game not necessarily
going to war on behalf of ukraine but
some skin in the game
may make the difference in uh convincing
putin uh
just
to rely on posturing and not actually
use force
great points let me ask you one
follow-up you mentioned president
putin's statement yesterday what do you
make of the defense minister the russian
defense minister's statement that
there's an american military private
american military companies in the don
boss and and they're
thinking about a chemical weapons attack
what does that mean
well as far as i can tell that's a total
fabrication but it's typical of what you
could expect the russians to do
uh to justify
an invasion and blame it on nato blame
it on the ukrainians i mean they're
using every uh argument that they can
muster they're they've
used the old broken promise about
nato enlargement supposedly made the
gorbachev which by the way somebody
raised this in the q a uh gorbachev
himself refuted this several years ago
and i'll put the reference in in the
chat after i finish speaking uh
but uh
fabricating the the idea that the us is
about to put hypersonic missiles or
tomahawk missiles
uh in ukraine uh when nato was announced
that it's not putting new missiles
anywhere even in response to the russian
violation of the inf treaty that's
something that also should be revisited
uh but uh he will cook up whatever myths
and fabrications he needs to convince
his own people that it's not russia's
fault uh but i don't think uh this is
going to be very convincing to the
international community
thanks sandy ambassador herbst you've
praised the biden administration for
handling the the crisis capably however
since the biden putin video call on the
7th putin has not de-escalated his
demands
on nato have only grown and it looks
like he got a meeting with the united
states without de-escalating is biden
blowing it how would you assess the u.s
so far the response
i i praised the initial response
uh when we during the press conference
tony blinken had with ukrainian foreign
minister kulepa in the middle of
november
where we laid out
the three things we would do
if moscow
invaded meaning major major sanctions
uh military arms to ukraine
and
putting out more nato forces in the
eastern allies
in other words in the baltic states and
poland to demonstrate to moscow that any
strategic gains i think they got in
ukraine they're going to lose elsewhere
unfortunately though
um we've seen alongside that initial
strong response
wavering
and weakness in dealing with kremlin
provocations
uh but i need to talk first about cyber
to explain this
uh
the kremlin has been provoking us on
cyber since may without any response
from the administration besides words
bind laid down clear red lines in geneva
which putin broke
in early july
bind laid down those clear red lines
again in phone calls to putin in july
and putin broke those in september and
october
at the same time we were looking like
patsy's working with russia on a joint
resolution to introduce the u.n on cyber
and worst of all the administration
released a major russian cyber criminal
to russia whom we spent years
extraditing
putin learned in cyber that he could
push biden around with impunity
and this may explain the difference
between the
crisis on ukraine's border in in the
spring and the crisis on ukraine's
border now
in the spring we effectively but we
effectively push um putin back
today we have not and this comes back to
now what's been happening since that
strong response in november
uh right after the strong response we
began to talk about a virtual summit
which again was as tether pointed out a
gift to putin
we have the summit
and what happens
we have
continuing russian provocations
the united states is talking about let's
have talks
and russia is talking about steps that
pave the way to war
this was especially noticeable
yesterday
when you had the russian defense
minister talking about this crazy
provocation of u.s introducing chemical
weapons into eastern ukraine and you
have tony blinking about talking about
how we're going to talk to russia in
january
it's like the bear versus the deer
and we know who wins in that scenario
so we have conveyed weakness
um
fairly regularly especially on cyber but
also on
on ukraine
now i need to make one more point i'm
sorry if i'm going on a little bit too
long
um i don't think we've reached or even
approached quite the point of no return
i don't have any doubt
that putin can turn his policy around on
a dime
um if he feels the need to
i agree um with andre and to a certain
extent with heather that putin is
playing for the concessions he will get
from us by threatening
and i don't have any doubt that there
will be many places in europe that will
you know uh issue a sigh of relief if
putin only for example grabs mariupol or
if putin only moves his troops halfway
from the russian border towards harkev
and say well look there's not no war
let's not put any sanctions down and
moscow could play play for that
and sadly i think there may also be some
people in washington who will have a
similar reaction
uh the game is
show strength we are far stronger than
russia in any category of national power
and while russia can
march into ukraine with impunity it will
take hits that andrew described
militarily if biden keeps his promises
on sanctions they'll take major economic
hits and putin understands that
we have a position of strength if we
make concept we've made concessions it's
been to our costs so far
um it's still not too late though to
make a very strong stand now
but we have to stop just talking about
having talks while moscow is threatening
war
thanks a lot john heather on john's
point on sanctions can you help us a
little bit because there's uh some
confusing signals so two weeks ago it
looked like the biden administration had
been doing all kinds of shuttle
diplomacy and putting together a really
strong package on sanctions it looked
like berlin and paris were two thumbs up
last week bloomberg reported that paris
and berlin were not two thumbs up and
that they wanted to talk rather than
think about sanctions are they going
wobbly what's what's the latest and if
there was a change why
well i i think on the one hand uh the
mind administration does need to be
commended um there was a lot of
consultation and and the european
council meeting last week produced a
very strong statement uh nato uh has
produced very strong statements so i
think they are very conscientious and
conscious that this this message of
strength and unity on sanctions but
you're absolutely right
beyond those rhetorical statements when
the rubber meets the sanctions road
that's where we're going to have
problems for the 27 european union
members uh additional sanctions against
russia requires unanimity
and that's going to be challenging uh
let's also be clear the type of
devastating sanctions that we are
talking about will have an equally
devastating impact on the european
economy at a time when energy prices are
very high exacerbated by russia's
squeezing and limiting energy supplies
through the yamal pipeline that is again
an added tactic of pressure as well as
as high inflation
and it is exactly as investor herbs
mentioned i mean europe takes its cues
in many respects from washington so when
washington starts uh
focusing on the dialogue and let me be
clear dialogue is important particularly
when tensions are high we have to keep
channels of communication open to moscow
but
when it seems like dialogue is uh in
some ways the path towards concession or
accommodation that's where um you then
started to hear as the white
administration was focusing on uh the
bilateral the u.s russia talks and then
the nato russia council osce then you
had president macron and now a
chancellor
in germany speaking to putin talking
about this dialogue but no one wants to
sacrifice their economy uh and during
these very challenging pandemic days
however
our principles are going to require
transatlantic sacrifice not only strong
military deterrence and support for
ukraine but if we hold these values we
are going to have to do this and i am
concerned
um that europe rhetorically is saying
the right thing but this is going to be
exceptionally difficult for all 27
countries to to really do very painful
painful steps so let's hope we don't
have to do that but uh i think you're
seeing the wobbliness because they're
they're not exactly sure where the u.s
is going to come out in this
thanks heather that that's that's great
insight if you're just joining us we
have five phenomenal experts and we are
discussing how to deter russia now we'd
love your questions if you're in zoom
with us go ahead and put those in the q
a if you're on twitter you can send them
to us i will read your question uh and
get a response i will direct it to the
right person general breedlove i'm
looking at you now so the biden
administration is talking about arming
ukrainian insurgents will that strategy
work
certainly as several of our panelists
have discussed we can uh help the
ukrainians to
increase the cost of taking reckless
action in ukraine and i believe that's
important that we saw that working
against them when they when russia went
into the dom boss and the mothers of
russia are revolting on what was
happening so i think that uh insurgents
would be a good thing a lot of words
have been used about what that would
look like i like to use an umbrella word
called resistance and actually the
baltic nations have wonderful programs
of resistance and this is a place that
the
nato may be able to actually reach
across the fence and help ukrainians i'm
sure they know how to do it in their
country but the fact of
organizing a resistance and all of the
insurgents words and and
um others that have been used can get
rolled up in that
thanks a lot sir do you have any other
advice that you would give to the
ukrainians right now
uh we'd love to hear your thoughts on
that
well
you know over the past four or five
years we've seen them build a very
capable army
and uh
it's it has acquitted itself well in the
field but the fact of the matter is they
are not prepared to defend themselves in
the air nor on the sea and all you have
to do is think back to the highway of
death out of kuwait or frankly just to
the last battles into baltimore about
what happens when you lose air
superiority over your troops and so we
can't let this army face that again we
they need to be asking us and we need to
be thinking about how do we better
organize their air defense and the same
could be said about counter defense
coastal defenses and other things to
give them some sea control
um
and as you saw just recently in the last
several days we've sent some cyber teams
there to help them because this this
gray zone attack that is going on now
not waiting for it the grayson attack
that is only intensified across the last
several weeks inside of ukraine needs to
be addressed and there are places that
we could help in these gray zone areas
our ukrainian brothers and sisters
thank you so much really important
points andrew i'd like to ask you uh
your foreign minister dmitry kaleva
wrote in foreign affairs that ukraine
needs air and missile defenses now he
also said that ammunition and medical
equipment are helpful
does sending these weapons deter putin
or or merely provide putin with another
pretext for invasion
no i think it's any any assistance from
the west
uh clearly helps to deter
and that's what we need the last thing
we need is to uh operate with the um
with the uh narratives that let's not uh
let's not poke putin you know because
that's that's clearly what reinforces
his uh behavior we need to understand
that the west jointly with ukraine are
capable to stop uh stop him he depends
on world economy he's not an isolated
country which exists you know in uh
self-sufficient so they they they depend
on the inflow of the uh you know of the
money from the west they they operate
from in the global uh
economic uh you know community and so on
and so on so turning off his uh his
economic capabilities and turning off
his ability to to be a a member of the
international finance system and so on
that that certainly helps and then
increasing has just discussed increasing
the cost of uh of the invasion up to the
point that
his advisors who are still lots of them
thinking reasonably they would be
understanding that it would be a
disastrous uh adventure to get there
which potentially can destroy their
regime inside back inside russia because
because as soon as they're going to lose
thousands of people a day as soon as
they will be able to uh not being able
to hold any occupied territories as soon
as they will be losing planes
helicopters and so on uh and the west
and the united states particularly can
help us to uh to reach that
uh and same thing in the scene i see
denial and and and so on so when when
the when the when all these pictures of
the destroyed equipment and kill people
will be just happening every day uh
people of russia will realize that this
doesn't make any sense uh and uh they
will have problems at home uh problems
with uh funding problems with money and
problems with the political stability
and they understand that we started lots
of their a lot of their materials they
do understand that so there is a there
is a conscious understanding of that
fact inside russia we just need to make
sure that that happens
andrew let me interrupt you and
challenge you you said you you seem to
think that that the ukrainian side is is
stronger than
than a lot of perceptions by analysts if
russia were to use its air force uh and
wipe out a couple of cities
how how how how would that hold up with
your analysis if they if they actually
remember
yeah of course we will look at that yes
they can they can they can do a lot of
damage they can do a lot of damage to
the to the security to sorry to the um
critical infrastructure and so on and
and and some cities as well but uh the
thing is that those actions will not
create any support to putin those
actions will make people uh essentially
and we studied the people's opinions a
lot uh people understand that if the war
gets to the like it gets real and gets
like
full-scale invasion and so they have
nothing to lose
and
essentially the majority of them would
be participating in whatever way they
can
so um so it's not the question of
getting to ukraine it's not a question
of advancing is the question what
happens after they
formally establish a certain control
over the territory how they actually
control it
and uh how many people they lose like
right next day after they claim they
controlled it
but it also depends on what they want if
their goal is to humiliate the west and
leave ukraine uh so destroyed that it
can't join nato they don't have to hold
a lot right well that's that's the point
because they uh they want to humiliate
the west right now and they want to uh
psychologically destroy any uh any any
desire to defend and so on ukraine has a
has an absolutely legal right and and
they wish to defend themselves ukraine
ukrainian people majority as as we just
discussed are ready to defend themselves
and uh i they understand that the post
will be will be will be very substantial
but so what do we what do we have to
lose there's no way we can agree to uh
stop westernization ukraine and stop
ukraine moving toward towards european
democracy which putin wants so
essentially the only thing we ask west
is not to be weak because weakness is
exactly what reinforces putin's opinion
uh putin's position uh nothing's going
to deter putin unless he sees that
there's no fear
and so if we don't demonstrate the fear
we ask our partners not to demonstrate
the fear that's what that's that's what
that's the only thing which we which we
which we need
andrew i think you're making a lot of
assumptions in your analysis when you
look at the levator polling it says that
50 of russians uh say that nato and the
united states are to blame for for this
and historically russians are not your
leader go ahead yeah but so what i mean
obviously they through the propaganda
they will be creating quite a lot of um
quite a lot of sort of uh illusions in
russian society there's no question
about that
the thing is that
the assumptions are based on the fact
that we see for example even kovid quite
substantially decreased the popularity
of putin's regime which is which is kind
of strange because generally speaking
you know they could manage that
information wise but they didn't and
then we have seen previously there was
lots of uh but again we're not
calculating our uh our position based on
how russian people react what we're
calculating our position is if ukrainian
people are ready to defend whatever the
scenario is and the answer is yes so the
only thing which we which we which we
need from the west is not to uh discount
us and not to say that okay uh if russia
starts your train stop existing so uh
take it for granted no it's not the case
ukraine will be defending itself very
very actively with lots of losses to
russia so you know unless putin is
completely crazy uh he shouldn't start
that scenario at all but i think you
have to dive into some of that data it's
true that that ukrainians defend
themselves but in
central ukraine the areas where putin
may be thinking about going in the
numbers are a lot lower if i were
vladimir putin i would see that as an
opportunity
what's the point for him to take regions
i mean what is what is the what is
actually strategic advantage of taking
one city or one or one region uh and
then and then and then uh and then
basically trying to hold it from the
rest of ukraine trying to get it back
and the world applying all these
sanctions which we discussed so actually
scenarios of actually keeping one city
or one small region or one and even a
large region uh this is this is a
scenario which brings him all all
negative parts and all negative kind of
consequences and uh and very few
positive so actually
how incredible it sounds but the only
way for to to to have any hopes of
holding this he should take a huge part
of the country but then it's a question
of how he's going to keep this huge part
of the country which is talked about
billions he spends every a year on uh on
so-called uh uh
lugansk and tunisia republics um
how he's going to where he's going to
find people to actually administer all
that uh how he going to keep those
capabilities
so that's um you know uh yeah advancing
is not a problem for him yes he can
establish air superiority and by the way
tactical aviation and the air defense
and and the navy are very weak against
insurgencies so so all these major uh
major advantages and capabilities they
actually against insurgencies they are
like very weak if
that's applicable at all so anyway
that's uh that's uh yeah that's where we
see it we see his losses coming up to
unbearable and um that's why we believe
his main plan like plan a for sure is to
like you know it's like in this game
like in a game theory they use this game
of two cars approaching one another and
then each of them hoping that the one
will will turn because no one who wants
to die so i think that that's that's
what he's playing and uh he plays that
the west will be weaker and start
negotiation and conceding super thank
you so much general if you wanted to
jump in go ahead
yeah we're running late let me yield
back
okay thank you sandy question for you
why is germany refusing to allow nato to
sell weapons to ukraine and is there any
way around germany's no
well i would say first of all it is
unfortunate that uh germany is getting a
reputation of uh
restricting support for ukraine at a
time when the west needs to be united
and showing that it's standing by
ukraine helping uh raise the costs to
the russians not only through sanctions
where i think the germans will will come
around i hope on nordstrom uh but also
in terms of military support
uh
this actual case that's been in the news
is is maybe not as big a deal as it has
been portrayed because it only pertains
to some specific weapons that the
ukrainians have been trying to get
from the nato support and procurement
agency nspa where there is a requirement
for allied consensus
and there were two systems in the end
the germans relented on some anti-drone
rifles which sounds like a pretty useful
capability given how the russians are
abusing uh the use of unmanned vehicles
uh they they held their ground in
denying
some
anti-sniper systems but
most by most the deliveries to ukraine
are bilateral and i hope that the
ukraine will not be uh just
uh disillusioned here uh it can go to
specific allies and hopefully get the
same capabilities maybe without the same
speed or
favorable financing
but but that they can still get them but
germany needs to think about what kind
of signals it's sending to putin uh this
is a policy i think that's carried over
from the merkel government but of course
schultz was part of that government
hopefully the greens who seem to be more
uh hard-line when it comes to supporting
ukraine militarily will bring about a
change in in the policy of the new uh
coalition i certainly hope so thanks
sandy that's really helpful ambassador
herbst you've been saying something
really interesting lately you said that
the single most important factor to
watch regarding how the situation plays
out is how putin feel uh views biden
does putin respect biden um i don't know
whether or not he respects him
but putin learned through his cyber
provocation that biden could be
challenged his buttons could be pushed
and he will not necessarily respond
and that's a very dangerous conclusion
for putin to draw
it doesn't mean that conclusion is for
all time
but the handling of the crisis on
ukraine's water over the past four or
five weeks
unfortunately contributes to that
opinion
um sandy mentioned for example the
handling of nordstrom 2.
um you had jake sullivan saying that
well perhaps if russia goes into ukraine
nordstrom 2 will be used
that perhaps that was more in russian is
a disaster
uh we need to send very clear signals
that we are going to strongly use all of
our power minus necessarily american
troops to make russia pay a very high
price
and we're not doing that right now
and that that can be changed overnight
but the white house has to realize that
if they continue to make concessions
even small ones to the kremlin
the kremlin will not back down they will
continue to threaten in order to gain
more concessions
and that's very serious problem
thank you ambassador herbs we have a
number of questions and i'm going to get
to as many as possible uh if you could
go ahead and unmute and be ready i'm
going to call on you quickly michael
gordon from the wall street journal
wants to know and i'm going to start
with general breedlove uh this is
michael's question karen donfried said
yesterday that if russia invades the us
will provide military to support to
ukraine above and beyond the current
package that is already flowing should
the u.s provide that additional military
support now and what specifically should
it provide in the limited time that may
be available for the ukrainians to
integrate it in their forces uh sir the
floor is yours
yes and we should provide things that
they can almost immediately use
and one of those things as was mentioned
before they do have some capabilities in
air defense but what they don't have is
the ability to lash it together to be
able to sense discern target and assign
weapons and there's things that we could
do almost immediately to help him with
that
could you give him any more specifics
i'm not gonna use weapons names people
always want to hang these things on
giving them one weapon which i think is
bogus we need to develop a capability
for them which is a series of things
that bring them to the ability to employ
wonderful thank you so much
sandy heather john andrew anyone else
want to answer michael all good andrew
please yes uh dealing with the us help
for from 2015 i can say that logistics
sometimes it takes extremely long time
so uh planning to do uh things after the
invasion or after invasion starts it's
almost uh inevitably gets us in
situation that will lose months probably
uh of of uh for delivery so so yes it
would make sense to start doing now to
in order to create this uh understanding
that the process has started uh the
capabilities are increasing and as we
are more ready so the readiness is
increasing and so readiness is the best
deterrent in any way as we as we say uh
so it absolutely would make sense to
start like as soon as
thank you thank you so much
sending weapons now would also send a
strong signal to putin that biden is
serious about stopping it should be done
now
thank you john uh okay question from
bill courtney uh in 2014 the kremlin
seemed to underestimate ukrainian's will
to resist in the don boss this is to
andreas the gourd new do you think the
krillin might still be doing that
and you're muted
andrew
uh yes they they may be uh maybe maybe
they they constantly underestimated
people they underestimated people in
2004
uh during orange revolution they did
this in
the uh
mine done the revolution of dignity and
they did it during the war then they
realized that and so they adjusted so we
believe
uh since they have
institutes of like large groups of
families walking in ukraine every day i
i think they should understand that and
they should should realize this what
they do underestimate is how weak may
their regular army may be and that's a
risk because they do not have an
independent uh either democratic or any
other oversight over the armed forces
the armed forces is a closed capsule
which reports directly to president uh
putin and they don't have any any
independent oversight uh that usually
brings the situation to the fact that
they overestimating their capabilities
because they each lay level of military
reporting uh reporting only good news
usually you know up upstairs so uh
usually that's a cold shower uh we they
had that in 2014 when they sent troops
and had loads of losses but the reason
is that they may be overestimating their
capabilities as we speak yes wonderful
thank you andrew sandy uh question from
uh mr gritsenko it's great to have you
with us uh mr grizzinko he says is it
not clear for the biden administration
that quote unquote implementing missed
agreements will kill both current
ukraine and its future if it is clear
then why is the u.s leadership repeating
that the minsk mantra even now i believe
to force ukraine to implement misc is
the main midterm objective of putin
what's your response to that yeah
and i understand the concern but i think
by the administration's trying to square
a circle here that's not necessarily
easy to square i mean the the fact of
the matter is the minsk framework i
emphasize framework rather than the
agreements in some literal sense is the
only basis for negotiations that we have
and there's a risk that if it's if you
try to put that to one side and start
from scratch
you're going to lose the vehicle that
still keeps the
european union united on sanctions
so i think the administration has to
make clear that minsk is the framework
but that we reject the one-sided
interpretation of mints that the
russians have been putting forward
and uh that we're prepared to engage in
the negotiations in a much more active
way to try to find some way to actually
implement the the intent of minsk which
is to restore
uh the occupied donbass to true
ukrainian sovereignty
but with some measure of local self-rule
in the occupied territories it may be
hard to do that and putin of course so
far has
made sure that russia has blocked any
real progress from the very first
signature of those minsk agreements but
if putin is convinced that it's time to
to make a deal
then i think there are ways forward that
preserve the framework of midst but
avoid some of the traps that the
russians have laid with their one-sided
interpretation
super thank you sandy question to andrew
again yeah this is from robert he says
is the case of in the case of a russian
invasion how loyal and reliable will the
ukrainian general staff be how big is
the danger of collaboration with russia
inside um at the senior senior staff
level
yeah that that that is one of the
few things which we have uh very little
risk about to be honest i mean to our
estimations again which are very
subjective right now most of the
uh most of the
senior leadership of general stuff and
generally military come on have been
replaced over the last couple years
and uh especially since the new
commander-in-chief came a general
solution and we see some very very
talented uh leaders there so
uh i wouldn't look at that as the some
you know any any any any risk or
whatsoever obviously people are people
and things happen but uh but from just
profiling them and understanding who
they are uh there's some people there's
some
some generals with with already with a
very deep battlefield experience been to
an action physically you know themselves
and so yeah so so for that perspective i
think our ukraine is quite strong very
strong actually super thank you question
for john and for general breedlove how
can black see nato countries contribute
in deterring russian aggression and
diluting the bargaining chips laid by
putin john go head first
well i think that there's
many countries around the black see that
understand the need to push back against
the kremlin romania ukraine georgia to a
lesser extent bulgaria and turkey
unfortunately
and increased nato patrols there i think
would be a welcome step
i think that
placing maybe some assets
defense assets um maybe even missiles
in romania perhaps also in ukraine
although that that would require closer
closer um consideration at this point in
time
um would give the russian black sea
fleet
pause
and uh other steps can be taken as well
there are there are under underwater
drones and actually actually i'm talking
beyond my my my expertise phil there's
more your stuff
so there are several things that could
be done and again it's sort of to the
question of speed the short-term things
that could be done is to bring some very
sophisticated coastal defense cruise
missiles to the area literally you could
control the entrance and exits to
sevastopol from the romanian coastline
if you wanted to
and we need to be then as we establish a
more immediate capability think about
how do we one increase nato
participation in the black sea american
participation is pretty good
and two how do we increase the
capabilities of those nations because
their naval capabilities are fairly
limited with the exception of turkey
which
tends to keep itself down in the
southwest corner of the black sea so as
not to come into conflict with the
russians
thank you so much general breedlove
heather question for you expanding are
the focus
do you have concerns that we could be
looking at a two-front war with russia
invading ukraine and china hitting
taiwan
or
maybe not a two-front war immediately
but that that china would look at and
and say it's a green light why not what
do you think about that so this is why i
think uh how the the west the by
demonstration or european colleagues
address this russia challenge sends a
clear message to all of america's allies
particularly in the indo-pacific and
yeah you know the questioner rightly uh
points out the increased sino-russian
alignment
um and of course uh we know president
putin at this point isn't going to
attend the beijing olympics
for those of you who recall your history
in 2008 in georgia olympics and
invasions and french presidencies of the
eu all at the same time feel like that
historical moment but uh not to put a
lighter touch on it but
the sign of russian collaboration
exactly what would stress the u.s
military capabilities the most
making a choice
between having to respond
to a challenge on nato's eastern plank
and having to continue to press
for ensuring ceilings of communication
are open uh in the south china sea and
indo-pacific and making sure that taiwan
is defended i you know again i think
this is
more about
how the west is going to address spheres
of influence whether that's in the
indo-pacific or in europe
will it do it with unity and with
strength and with courage
or will it accommodate
accommodate until there is a larger
crisis and i think that that really is
the key but continue to look to uh xi
jinping and vladimir putin talking a lot
more coordinating things at the united
nations and other places they are you
know it's a condominium is growing as an
anti-western
approach so we have to keep this in mind
very much as we continue to to
strengthen our principles and and
international law thank you heather
general breedlove a question from chris
are the turkish drones a game changer
encountering putin
well let's let's again not talk about
one
weapon system changing everything a good
drone capability that is
wrapped into
ukraine's command and control system so
that they can bring to re bring risk to
russian armored forces and russian
mobile forces invading ukraine for the
third time
um that would be a good thing
fabulous thank you ambassador herbs this
is a really interesting question is it
possible the military buildup is a cover
for the actual tactical objective which
could be regime change through internal
um
internal subterfuge in ukraine if you
put enough pressure on zilinski that he
will blink and give special powers to
the l r d dnr or worse there's intel um
inter provocations um is this enough to
split ukrainian society could this be
the game or do you do you think that
it's really about the military i think
that the build-up is designed to produce
concessions from either ukraine the
united states
the germans the french the eu
um and what you've described i think
might be
very high on the kremlin wish list but i
think it's highly unlikely to happen
bob they can produce
some small fissures in ukrainian society
or exploit some small fissures in
ukrainian society but as you know
melinda a large majority of ukrainians
are prepared to defend their sovereignty
and their territorial integrity and this
game will not go very far
putin's aggression in ukraine going back
to 2014 has made him the father of
current ukrainian nationalism
great thank you
uh general breedlove another question
for you um when the bite administration
says no american troops on the ground in
ukraine does that also include no b2s or
f-35s in the air
is that a possibility or what could you
help us parse that
well i can't speak for the president
about what he means but uh
factually no boots on the ground can be
accomplished by a lot of air power so
we'll just
leave it at that
okay super thank you thank you so much
unfortunately we are at time we have to
conclude today by thanking uh our
distinguished panel thank you so very
much two of them are on vacation and
they agreed to do this anyway you guys
are heroes i'd like to thank uh bernard
henry levy for his welcoming remarks and
i'd also like to thank the harvard uh
center and the temporary foundation for
making this event possible folks this
subject is not going away and we're
going to be doing it again on january 6
we wish you happy holidays and we wish
ukraine peace and prosperity and the
american the united states as well happy
holidays and see you back in january
thank you so much bye-bye
c-span's washington journal every